all right we are now live for another
reading from my book
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in
france which came out 10 years ago i'm a
little bit behind the times
it only occurred to me i should start
doing some readings from the book this
year
and we're about um well we're more more
than halfway through it you can see here
by looking at the pages and today we're
going to begin with a reading of one of
the chapters that will probably take us
three or four
to get through because there's there's
quite a bit here
and this is maurice blondel's the
problem of catholic philosophy
published in laissez tude philosophique
uh
volume seven number one in 1933 and this
is uh subtitled meeting of the society
detude philosophique presentation of 26
november 1932 and i should say just a
little bit about this in terms of format
because what we have here is a
presentation by maurice blondell and
blondel at this time was nearly blind it
wasn't easy for him to travel
or you know go around different places
and
you know much of what he was doing had
to be
carried out you could say
remotely you know sort of like what
we're doing here
and so he he has his presentation
and then there are letters
uh letters that people wrote and that
blondel responded to
enrico castelli was one of the
letter writers and then we get
bloondell's response
uh john devil vey very difficult person
to translate because his french is so
atrocious was another one of the
philosophers uh then we have andrey
guiller the great historian of
philosophy who is involved in this and
then we get a real treat uh joseph
mareshall
the great um
transcendental thomas before ronner and
lonigan very influenced by blondel by
the way and then after that there's
there's a transcript of a discussion
that takes place between
blondel
jacques paliar and gaston berger so this
is a significant portion of the book
because there's a lot going on here so
i'm just going to read blondel's own
presentation
today and then uh
next time about doing
as much the letters as we can get
through so no further ado here is the
problem of catholic philosophy
by maurice blondell
under the name of christian or even
catholic philosophy which has been used
in very different ways since the second
century and has reappeared down the
course of the ages even on titles of
lengthy works
is something else hidden besides a
literary expression or a historical
label useful perhaps for designating
certain movements within civilization in
general
but lacking possible definiteness and
technical justification in short
from the rational point of view
is it not wrong
for us to speak of a problem that would
be up for debate as the object of a
critical examination
an examination that even if it must be
concluded with a negation
provides an occasion for deepened
analyses and systematic solutions
many people either have not dreamed of
such a question or have decided it was
not worth a thorough treatment because
in this verbal reconciliation there
would be only a superficial confusion
between two domains having no reason to
enter into contact into agreement or
contact
philosophy develops itself freely in its
plane which claims its own plenary
autonomy and which seems to constitute
philosophy in itself
christianity is something surplus it
justifies itself or works itself out in
a plane totally different in its origins
its methods its aims and its promises
consequently
some conclude
there uh
here we go consequently some conclude
these are two lines that cannot cross
each other nor even claim to a
parallelism and a convergence towards
infinity
because it is a matter of heterogeneous
planes one fact however constantly ends
up contesting this simplistic verdict
there is no encounter they tell us no
collision between true philosophy and
authentic christianity
and yet what spectacles do the insistent
antagonisms or the renewed efforts that
interpenetration offer us throughout the
ages
if this chronic condition possesses an
intelligible signification is it not
philosophy's role to seek out its causes
and to discern its enduring reasons for
perhaps it is right to repeat about
christianity what aristotle declared
about metaphysics
here's a footnote
there's no bone sites both aristotle and
himself here is about the supernatural
order that is especially right to repeat
the statement of aristotle about
philosophy if we must not philosophize
we still must philosophize one cannot
exclude metaphysics
except by a metaphysical critique this
comes from oxyo 1893
so back to the text itself
and even if we should not do that well
then let us seek out and understand
why it can or must be eliminated
from a first point of view there is
already a problem to scrutinize more
closely and more methodically than has
typically been done and our first task
is to investigate why people have turned
their attention away from a difficulty
that nevertheless has never been
eliminated and with a little bit of
reflection we perceive that this
deficiency contains another deeper more
intrinsic difficulty
that of
precisely determining the real point of
encounter
between the philosophical spirit and the
christian spirit as immense as the
distance between them seems
even though for so many centuries during
the history of thought this apparently
productive distancing has never
prevented collisions or alliances
between the two great spiritual powers
disputing or sharing between themselves
rulership over intellects and souls
when at the beginning of christian
reflection
saint justin the philosopher or clement
of alexandria glimpsed or wished for a
philosophy according to christ a
catholic gnosis
they anticipated a realization of it
that did not lie in their power and that
even as saint augustine did not himself
see
except in an implicit way divided as he
was between the customary meaning of
philosophy that ancient philosophy
already possessed and the aspiration
towards a synthesis whose intelligible
explanation and satisfactory term the
eternal word alone would give
by the teaching through which he
illuminated reason and by the good news
of the god-man
between the ancient and cyclical
conception of philosophy
whether a rationalizing or empirical one
and the concrete and infinite ideal of
thought and the destiny proclaimed or
imposed by the incarnate words preaching
the abyss was too vast for even the work
of genius to possibly fill
hence the long history of the more or
less fortunate more or less failing or
stimulating attempts of a thought that
by organizing a closed philosophy and a
conceptual order according to hellenic
science's static inspiration
sought at the same time to juxtapose to
superimpose christian truths on rational
truths by fitting them together so to
speak
through theses common to both but by
asserting all the more the supernatural
orders
transcendence and gratuity
a salutary effort a precious and
indispensable distinction a place for
agreement and conversation but between
powers that if we remain within this
conceptual perspective
remain foreign
eccentric and opposed to each other
it is not surprising then that by
retaining the ancient ideal of a
philosophy sufficing onto itself and
finishing itself in concept some would
have awaited have avoided approaching
head on the question of a true symbiosis
of a purely rational activity and of a
thought intelligibly submitted to the
faith
instead of an intimate connection
allowing a cooperation without confusion
they have instead examined the notional
agreement of more or less objectively
superimposable doctrines
from such a viewpoint they have been
able to talk about christian philosophy
in three slightly different senses
before going on to show the deficiencies
of these different ways of understanding
the litigious expression under
discussion we can summarize them thus
number one
certain theses like the affirmation of
god of the spiritual soul of personal
immortality are truths that philosophy
normally can and even ought to establish
in parallel with the revealed teaching
that confirms them
provides them precision and expands them
by purifying them from doubts troubles
and errors
already this consortium of truths common
to reason and to faith established it
seems a solid base for a doctrine
meriting the double name of rational and
christian
in this first sense christian philosophy
appears to bear essentially on a middle
zone where two lights converge on
ontologically identical objects despite
the formal difference of their modes of
knowledge and of certainty
two
in addition
the christian contribution is served
historically as a vehicle for truths
that speculation was not able to
discover and that perhaps are naturally
weak or accidentally weakened reason
would not have been able to attain by
its own powers alone
in actuality the clear idea of creation
for example was not worked out by reason
and it was the judeo-christian
revelation that introduced it into the
history of ideas and made it available
for philosophical thoughts mastication
by right certain metaphysical truths
seem inaccessible to reason even though
once revealed they offered a speculation
a gripping point
it is legitimate to take advantage of
not in order to violate a mystery but in
order to show in it a consolation rather
than a darkening as is the case for the
divine trinity of which a plague or
others seem to have a vague presentment
and from which our christian doctors
drew some illuminations suited for
removing different objections against
the mystery of divine personality
in this sense christian philosophy is no
longer simple confirmation but extension
and growth for rational thought itself
three
if the history of concepts was enriched
by a sort of secular digestion of
partially rationalizable revealed truths
a yet more deeply penetrating
justification of christian philosophy
has been proposed a lived one little by
little penetrating the entire
intellectual civilization
and the intellects experiencing in
themselves human natures and
supernatural grace is double labor
in this sense saint augustine saint
bonaventure and others could speak of a
philosophy that is no longer only that
of natural reason
but of the new being under the
irradiation of the soul and same
interior master the eternal word of god
christ mediator revealer and redeemer
who imposes on every man coming into the
world the same clarity illuminating from
within the same unavoidable destiny
we are far from thinking of failing to
recognize such a labor of elucidation
and reconciliation's rightness and
usefulness it has contributed to prepare
little by little the true problem to
raise not at all by filling the abyss we
have seen between ancient doctrines and
quote philosophy according to christ
but to the contrary by making the very
conception of philosophy
evolve and by preparing discernment of
what remains incommensurable between the
rational order and the supernatural
order
even when set by
side by side
for it is not the interval of concepts
that is to be filled to the contrary it
is reasons insufficiency that must be
shown and opened up once it is a matter
of satisfying our minds metaphysical
demands and of discerning or satisfying
the calls of our restless and mysterious
destiny
in certain respects the partial use some
have tried to make of revealed teachings
has maintained an equivocation that has
not always been favorable to the
authentically christian spirit and if it
is true that theological data have often
been a philosophical leaven
is this fermentation has taken advantage
less of certain theses partially
assemble similable to this or that
rational system
than of an enlivening of the method and
the function of philosophy itself
the ideas that a descartes or a male
brush were able to lend to the catholic
tradition were in the speculative use it
made of them contestable or even wrong
but they have contributed to transposing
the ancient conception according to
which the world is a cyclical order and
a hierarchy of fixedly defined forms
into a greater problematic one more
moving more real more intelligible and
better
a dramatic problem that presents the
universe and humanity
as the history of a genesis of an
ascension of an aspiration towards the
infinite or even towards a union
unaccessible to man whose natural desire
exceeds his very nature
it therefore required centuries and
multiple attempts at mutual adaptations
of reason and faith in order for a
problem to become explicit a problem
implicit
from the time of christian origins on
but for a long time asked by an effort
of notional concortism when it was
really a question of clarifying and
justifying metaphysical possibility a
spiritual grafting and a vital
cooperation
if since saint justin the philosophy
according to christ drawn on like credit
seemed according to antiquities reason
to have to eliminate philosophy
it could not always suffice during the
conflicts of the truces and what
appeared an ever-renewed duel to work
out peace treaties by marking out the
borders or the middle zones of influence
for this again and again always amounts
to materializing or conceptualizing the
two spiritual powers meriting this name
only if a cooperation a symbiosis
an intucception replaces the notion of
an antagonism or a purely extrinsic
complementarity
it was therefore necessary that the
philosophy according to christ far from
repressing that of the philosophers
welcomed it animated it recognized it
and satisfied its most legitimate its
most audacious demands
and this required that of christianity's
reciprocal demands and what was most
wounding and in appearance and
commensable for reason in them by this
specifically supernatural rigor became
the condition for encounter for
collision for insertion
from which the philosophical order in
the christian order must doubly benefit
it is therefore
insofar as the christian contribution
introduces supernatural data and demands
that it procures a decisive and
elevating renewal for the philosophical
spirit not at all simply by presenting
ideas from which reason draws augmented
precision and more elaborated systems
of philosophy as of all the human
disciplines christian thought has been
able to say echinova facio omnia yes but
by a slow and obscure mastication
assuredly it would be wrong to fail to
recognize the fertility of the
historical and speculative effort that
has little by little if one may say so
digested the news com comprised in the
good news
but these particular news only have
their meaning and their worth by being
referred to the radical and unique
newness that has to be envisaged
accepted incorporated in its integrity
it is to this task that philosophy will
itself oh its completeness and
comprehensiveness
and it is in this perspective that we
can speak not only of a philosophy more
or less colored by christianity but of
catholic philosophy completely different
from a concordance or christianoid
doctrine of which the past offers many
examples since by wanting to tally up
all the actions or reactions the
christian influence has determined some
have gone as far as a nietzsche and even
well beyond him in understanding it
from such a viewpoint i hope we will
admit that the development of modern
thought has had this effect of bringing
the always looming crisis
between rational autonomy and christian
demands to a vital point that historical
exegetical and apologetic considerations
do not reach
insofar as they appear in isolation
without the preliminary question
being raised
the question whose precise meaning
normal character and essential scope we
have just tried to exhibit
granted not everyone has the need to
pass through this dominating problem but
for the philosopher who wants to and
ought to take ra account for himself of
metaphysical possibilities rational
demands moral legitimacies and
obligations the problem we have tried to
articulate seems inevitable and it is to
the extent that one has resolved it in
an explicit or an implicit way that the
history of these philosophically
christian efforts takes on their useful
meaning their subordinate value their
preparatory role their salutary
usefulness
otherwise
rationalist critique would be quite
right to triumph over the equivocations
to render justice to all too easy
concortisms to show how the christian
theses cease being christian in order to
become philosophical or cease to be
philosophical in order to remain
christian otherwise the modernists would
still be led to confuse christianity's
generative idea with the human forms
that it has clothed itself in and that
starting from its origin seemed to them
a perpetual metamorphosis under the
backlashes of philosophical speculation
or historical contingencies
nothing of this sort if at the start the
problem of the supernatural is
determined in all of its precision by a
rational critique that shows its
legitimacy and inevitability
how the problem is led by an unbending
critique of thought and of life
how this examination ends up in a
philosophy open not only to a vague and
amorphous empty space but to one that
stimulates openings and is capable of
providing precision to the ultimatum of
a reason that does not remain content
with close enough or gratuitous
hypotheses how definite contours
experimental verifications are possible
and required
these issues are what we cannot examine
here in their indispensable developments
our intention is only to explain a
little
of why the problem of a christian
philosophy raised virtually for many
centuries has been ordinarily avoided at
the least approached often obliquely
method
methodically little disgust
how has it become a more pressing more
contemporary more renewing problem
why must it not be approached solely
from the historical point of view as if
it did not remain the doctrinal problem
par excellence
under what multiple aspects does it
participate in the permanent and
universal character of metaphysical
restlessness and in the perenniality of
the religious aspiration and of the good
news always new
this is what i have in mind to propose
from my friends reflection and
discussion
it is not therefore surprising that many
of my correspondents should have been
led to enlarge the terms of the debate
for if it is true that from the strictly
rational point of view and from a
specifically religious point of view an
irreducible heteroj heterogeneity and an
inevitable solidarity subsist at the
same time our problem restricted in
appearance to a particular case has this
touch on philosophy summit in its
encounter with the question of
religion's life or death of what in
religion is positive in living
yes or no can philosophy suffice onto
itself and suffice for us isolate itself
and close itself off subjugate the
religious sentiment and even the
religious idea and see in the faith only
a popular irzots for science and
rational speculation
or then
must we affirm as philosophers and
maintain as men
the legitimacy the reality the
indestructible originality of positive
religions thought and life in humanity's
breast
and in the gaze of metaphysical sp
speculation faced with history or in the
witness of more and more verified
experience is it not the religious
universalist spirit that confers on the
god of the philosophers the vitality
lacking which he remains only a still
debatable name about which a debate can
be opened a debate that can hardly be
called anything but the debate about
atheism here's a footnote blondel is
here referring to the society francis de
philosophies session of march 1928
bearing that name
therefore it is a sovereign importance
to be able to examine in all simplicity
and entire frankness the dominating
question bearing on what has been
rightly called the whole of thought and
the whole of life not that we have here
to fix conclusions in their exact
content a too literal conformism is not
at all enlivening and cannot suffice for
us far from that
nothing ever authorizes exclusion of
philosophical freedom nor failure to
recognize
an invisible and catholic soul of truth
always the use of the means of
illumination and charity should be
recommended as should inviolable respect
for consciences the quest for and cult
of peace and art and cooperation of
minds who have to show the value of
their investigations and their
convictions solely by the arms of light
per arma lucas
it is on this last aspect that i would
like to end this brief summary
for our dialogues will not be useless if
we succeed even feebly in favoring the
realization of the wish that mr devil
vey sends us from toulouse by our very
discussions to produce an assimilation
and a deepening of rational speculation
and of religious tradition for
re-establishment of spiritual communion
that is where
maurice blondel's presentation ends
and um what follows are the letters
received regarding mr maurice blondel's
presentation with responses by mr
blondel as i mentioned we have um four
of these sets of letters
um
one set by enrico castelli
um
an interesting uh
italian philosopher who's also if i
remember write a go-between at one time
between heidegger and blondel uh mr jean
del volve
and then
two really important uh figures henry
guilier the really great historian of
philosophy i don't think a lot of his
works have been translated unfortunately
but he is just a giant in
french history of philosophy and then
joseph mareshall the jesuit who
unfortunately was never allowed by the
jesuits teach graduate level classes uh
for for i forget the reason exactly why
but he is one of the fathers of
transcendental tomism so they write
letters maurice blondel responds to them
and then there's a discussion between
blondel jacques paliar and gaston
bergere
berger
covering these issues as well and so
it's it's a quite a a lengthy part of
the book runs from page 182 to page 224
so
you know we're talking about over 40
pages
in a book that is
over all
uh
a little over 300 right so
we'll pick up with uh some of that next
time
again the book is reason fulfilled by
revelation 1930s christian philosophy
debates in france so now we've got some
time for some uh discussion and q a
a lot of people saying hi
charlie says i love your work it's so
insightful thanks that's nice to hear
it doesn't always feel that way
as you're
doing the work
it's like anything else when you see how
the sausage is made
you know you have a very different
perspective on it
mario says would you say philosophers
are more demanded than ever in the age
of ai so
everything turns on the word demanded
uh is there a greater demand like a
market demand for philosophers i would
say
no not really i mean there have always
been intelligent people outside of
philosophy doing things who said oh we
need to bring in somebody who knows
about this this area you know could be
like uh
how formal systems work or it could be
ethics it could be whatever you want
um but unfortunately i would say most
people in the business world
they know very little about philosophy
and a lot of what they think they know
about it is unfortunately like stuff
that's not real philosophy but just sort
of pre-digested things you know what
they learned from their instructor about
what aristotle said and aristotle is an
empiricist which is not actually true
but if you're talking in the moral sense
uh
you know should philosophers be involved
in
discussions about ai
and its many uses and its extension into
things
absolutely i mean
you know philosophers should be and are
involved in discussions about whether
there is such a thing as ai or whether
this is just a big metaphor same thing
with like machine learning it's not
really learning in a real sense
but it's it's an interesting set of
processes and you know what are the
dangers on the horizon what are the
things that we're overlooking what are
the ethical quandaries that are going to
come up because of
ai and it's many different uses what
what counts as a.i you know clarifying
that
yes i would say that um philosophers do
need to be involved in that
i don't know that that has much to do
with the christian philosophy debate
other than to say that
you know in a very broad sense so
blondel is signaling that
philosophy as a wide field and
christianity
can't can't really avoid each other and
when they try to when when philosophy
says oh that's irrational that doesn't
mean anything philosophy loses some of
its philosophic nature
um christianity likewise when it when it
tries to impose on philosophy hey just
just do the philosophy that's gonna you
know provide us the apologetics we need
it it actually becomes in some respects
non-christian
um and and i would say today that there
are many people out there
masquerading as christians in our
culture who aren't remotely christian
are actually antichrist
and you know that's a much larger
conversation to have but philosophy
could play a role
in helping to
discern those sorts of things
and there are christian philosophers
engaged with that that sort of thing
all right any other questions
comments issues about what we covered
with blondel
the uh topic of christian philosophy
um the historical doctrinal
uh methodological connections that he
sees as important in bringing a crisis
to to bear
mario's is a follow-up i'm asking
because i'm doing a
mc my master's of science i guess
in digital leadership and new age
technologies and part-time learning all
great philosophical works like heidegger
hegel nietzsche and even stoics yeah i
mean all of those thinkers actually have
something to say about technology so i
think that you know that
is relevant
um there's plenty of others as well so
yeah um
roughly bumble has a good question here
do any of the 1930s thinkers offer any
thoughts
on the christian understanding of the
soul during the debate yes and no
so nobody in the
course of the debates
is saying all right i'm going to take a
step back and focus just on this issue
and not look at the larger
context so i'm going to do a treatise on
the soul or something like that
there are some you know discussions of
it for example in jill songs the spirit
of medieval philosophy
where he's he is taking the historical
approach that blondel is saying isn't
isn't enough and blondel is right about
that by the way
um blondel's position and jillson
maritan's position are actually
complementary to each other as many of
the people in the debates pointed out
um
i wouldn't say that there's there's like
any advance in like proposing new new
understandings of the soul in in the
course of these debates that said um a
lot of these thinkers in their other
works are definitely discussing the soul
so you know blondel marcel
um you know martin um
jillson as i mentioned
um even some of the rationalists like
brahiar you know in his history of
philosophy he's interested in what
people thought about things so even
though he doesn't accept these ideas he
will talk about you know christian ideas
of the soul
so
do they offer insights um
[Music]
not any really new insights in the
debates
but um you know they certainly
uh highlight the importance of like
understanding a person as a person as
something that develops
in significant part through christianity
um
and it's not as if the pagan thinkers
didn't have any notion of that
but like blondel pointed out there's
often ideas
that
put into a new context suddenly people
can see
what's there
and we can say that's not just about
christianity we can say this about other
respects in which
we expand our viewpoint you know the
technology thing is a great example
we inhabit a very different world now
than even just like heidegger did back
in the 50s 60s um you know
uh let alone back in 1928 or anything
like that it's it's
we are in a different environment and we
have new philosophical issues that
aren't totally radically new
they're naturally informed by other
thinkers think about aristotle and what
he has to say about technology and power
relations and stuff like that
um but we can get a different point of
view on it and i kind of think that
you know when it comes to issues like
the soul or human nature
these are things that you know there are
many viewpoints on but all those
viewpoints are at best partial and not
fully adequate and we're still in the
process of figuring out what the hell we
are you know like with human nature
all right so ricky has a question what
did blondel's contemporaries think of
him they loved him and they hated him as
a matter of fact that goes on even today
where there's still a lot of uh
basically ignorant people out there who
hate blondel just because of what other
people back then said about him
blondel's thought was so influential
that he is often talked about
as the philosopher of vatican ii
and if you read john paul the second
fiji cedrazio about christian philosophy
blondel is not mentioned in it and
that's because blown it's a blundellian
document so
he has had massive influence
he was hated by quite a few
of the catholic thinkers of his time who
i actually consider to be in many
respects deficient catholics like um
garagu lagrange who who attacked
blondel's work and admitted that he
couldn't understand blondel's work um
[Music]
but there are many who really
well and also say too jilson mara 10
didn't like blondel
and
a lot of that was like personality
conflict stuff which is kind of weird um
there were a lot of
french thinkers who thought that blondel
was probably one of the most important
thinkers of the 19th and 20th centuries
and they included many thomas including
somebody who we're going to get to a
little bit later
in the book um antonin sertian
who is
uh
yeah oh that's coming right after this
in chapter eight
and bruno de salaj and uh andre de
lubeck and you know all these other
things so blondel is is fairly neglected
these days um
but
he is a first-rate philosopher
who um
people recognized as such at the time
john says i have no questions yet thank
you as always for your work you're very
welcome so
any other questions comments things
people want me to tackle otherwise we'll
end a little bit early and i'll get to
my
class work my students are
totally burnt out in their last
week of class
at one place and the second to last week
of class in another it has been a very
tough semester for these poor kids
um and it doesn't i was just talking
with a colleague is it gonna get better
in the spring probably not you know
we're probably we have another year to
grind out maybe before we
start to get back to something
resembling normalcy but that's a total
side note not related to this christian
philosophy stuff
all right well if there aren't any other
questions i'll i'll say next week uh
doing another reading continuing on in
this this section
and thanks for all of your questions and
comments
and
i'll see you next time